[Music]
i'm keith cohen i'm the owner of all
washers bakery we're in one of new york
city's oldest and most iconic food
establishments so here we have isaac and
enrique showing us how we make the
bagels every day here we have two
different types of starters that we use
so we have our natural
sourdough starter along with a special
bigger it's our bagel beaker after the
starters are added to the mixers we add
in the malt and honey we have flour
water
salt yeast
right now we're making a hundred pound
mix this mix here makes 30 dozen bagels
we're mixing and incorporating on a low
speed and then developing the gluten
more on a higher speed our mixer allows
the bowl to turn as well so it's a
little bit more gentle on the dough
so after it's mixed okay almost like
working out right you've developed
gluten you need to rest you need to rest
in between sets it's important for us to
be very gentle with the dough we
cut the dough into 17 pound increments
and let it rest in these buckets
what's going to happen with the dough is
when you first take it out of the bowl
it's going to feel pretty stiff and hard
by the time it's done resting you'll
feel it relax more
now that the dough is rested we're going
to bring it over the hydraulic divider
so this hydraulic divider has probably
been around for the past 60 70 years
very simple machine and the more modern
ones that we have allow these different
grids the grid will give us 60 even
pieces so we can shape later into the
baker's
[Music]
so after it's divided in the divider we
want to put it on our boards and let it
rest a bit so it's going to relax again
so we can roll it out correctly time is
really critical you cannot be too fast
nor too slow because the dough has a
mind of its own you know heat humidity
cold will all affect the timing of the
final product
now that we've realized the dough is
relaxed and ready to go it takes a lot
of hands a lot of quick hands in order
to be able to roll this out to be able
to put it back on the board so we can
give it a final rest before it goes into
the refrigerator
when the dough is relaxed it's a lot
easier to flatten out the piece and from
there you work your hands from the
center out in order to develop a mini
baguette so once you're comfortable with
the length of it the double seal and
you're ready to put it on the boards
hand speed is super important it's
inherent in bakers they need good hand
speed just like if you're an athlete and
it takes time you have to work with your
group of acres in order to develop that
pace and also that cadence just like any
good team
here we have the bagels resting on the
boards
it is critical to leave them out a
little bit to give them one little final
rest before they go in the refrigerator
overnight
in the morning they pull the bagels out
of the refrigerator and then they go
into our deck oven the deck oven is kept
somewhere around 450 degrees and the one
key element is making sure we have
enough steam in terms of not boiling the
bagel now people would say that's a
sacrilege and i understand why fact that
we have steam as opposed to a regular
bagel oven that's just dry heat i
thought it could take the place of the
boil and in fact it has and every five
minutes almost you can see the bagel get
a little bit bigger you're going to get
this mahogany crust that you want with a
regular boiled bagel what do i want in a
bagel i want a nice chew i want flavor i
want somebody to eat it and not go into
a food coma
you can eat it on its own you can eat it
as a sandwich you can have it as a piece
of toast i think bagels are one of the
most universal foods out there and that
is how bagels are made
you